jp nécessaires pour faire face ont plu
fiction posent à notre temps on y voit
un thème que l'ouest est un climat
particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire et des violences sous prétexte
d'une manifestation et d'expression de
droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on ainsi que m
est-ce que sincèrement vous êtes
certains que le scrutin du 31 octobre
sera maintenu à la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
écologie réindustrialisation emploi le
plan de relance tant attendue de
l'économie française est désormais connu
100 milliards d'euros sur la table et 70
mesures pour tenter de sortir la france
de la crise engendrée par le cos vie de
c'est l'un des derniers plans à avoir
été dévoilé en europe aux états-unis les
drames se suivent et se ressemblent un
afro-américain de 18 ans a été tué par
la police hier après avoir fui un
contrôle
dans le même temps la famille de daniel
preuve d'un homme noir de 41 ans mort en
mars dernier une semaine après son
interpellation a diffusé une vidéo de
son arrestation sa famille demandent à
ce que les agents de police en cause
soient poursuivis pour homicide
tous les détails dans ce journal
[Musique]
les interrogations persistent au sujet
de la sphère navalni l'union européenne
appelle moscou à une enquête et n'exclut
pas des sanctions
de son côté le président biélorusse
l'assurent ils détiendraient la preuve
que le présumé empoisonnement de
l'opposant russe a été falsifiée par les
occidentaux
objectif dissuader moscou d'intervenir
en biélorussie secoué par un mouvement
de contestation inédit depuis un mois a
par ailleurs l'otan prévoit une réunion
vendredi à bruxelles au sujet du dossier
navale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france et on
débute avec le plan de relance de
l'économie présenté en début de l'après
midi par jean castex en conseil des
ministres france relance c'est le nom du
plan prévoit 100 milliards d'euros et 70
mesures pour surmonter la récession
économique due à la crise du coronavirus
avec trois priorités
les précisions des lames et jane le
premier volet porte sur la transition
énergétique à hauteur de 38 milliards
d'euros 11 milliards sont alloués aux
mobilités du quotidien savoir les
transports en commun ou encore le plan
vélo 7 milliards d'euros sont prévus
pour la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics
les particuliers pourront aussi
bénéficier de ma prime rénove dès le 1er
janvier prochain
enfin 9 milliards d'euros sont affectés
à l'accompagnement des entreprises dans
leur transition énergétique
le deuxième volet s'affiche comme un
plan de réarmement industriel avec 35
milliards d'euros pour la compétitivité
française
le plan prévoit une baisse des impôts de
production de 20 milliards sur deux ans
qui bénéficiera en majorité à
l'industrie et au commerce
3 milliard d'euros seront par ailleurs
consacrés au renforcement des fonds
propres des entreprises qui se sont
lourdement endettés
pendant la crise le troisième volet pour
la cohésion sociale et territoriale
représente 35 milliards d'euros dont 15
milliards pour l'emploi un plan de 6
milliards et demi pour la formation et
l'emploi des jeunes
exclusivement des sommes d'ores et déjà
débloqué par le gouvernement
7 milliards 600 millions d'euros sont
également accordés pour l'activité
partielle de longue durée
enfin une enveloppe sera débloqué pour
soutenir l'investissement des
collectivités
une somme est aussi prévue en soutien à
l'investissement des hôpitaux dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé écologie
réindustrialisation emploi on connaît
donc les priorités du plan de relance
tant attendue de l'économie française
ah c'est l'un des derniers à être
dévoilés en europe alors ce plan est il
à la hauteur des enjeux qu'elle dépense
véritablement nouvelle contient-il
écoutez l'analyse
l'économiste jacques sapir on a présenté
ce plan comme un plan excessivement
ambitieux et c'est vrai qu'avec 100
milliards d'euros il y à une somme qui
en apparence est tout à fait
considérable
après il faut comprendre que ce plan est
nécessaire parce que l'économie
française est actuellement exsangue il y
a eu évidemment les deux mois de
confinement
il ya certes eu un petit rebond après le
confinement mais on voit en particulier
sur les chiffres du mois d'août sur les
chiffres d'activité du mois d'août on
voit que l'activité est en train de
retomber
et donc il faut absolument relancer
cette activité alors c'est un plan
important mais c'est un plan qui d'une
certaine manière mélange des dépenses
mais aussi tout simplement des
abattements d'impôts donc des déductions
fiscales
or ces déductions fiscales les fameuses
impôts sur la production
eh bien ce sont des ressources pour les
collectivités locales et donc il faudra
d'une certaine manière les compenser et
tout cela
d'une certaine manière ne contribue pas
à la lisibilité de la politique du
gouvernement
tensions toujours vives aux états unis
après la mort d'un afro-américain hier à
washington
l'homme de 18 ans a été tué par la
police après avoir fui un contrôle dans
le même temps à la famille de daniel
près d'un homme noir de 41 ans mort en
mars dernier une semaine après son
interpellation a diffusé une vidéo et on
y voit le déroulement de l'arrestation
de daniel preuve sa famille demandent à
ce que les agents de police en cause
soient poursuivis pour homicide
explications avec françois 10 km h
chaque jour son nouveau drame cette fois
ce mercredi à washington
plusieurs dizaines de personnes
manifestent devant un commissariat après
la mort d'un homme noir tué par la
police
âgé de 18 ans il aurait fut un contrôle
les agents ont alors ouvert le feu
craignant que le jeune homme ne soit
tard mais je ne sais vraiment pas dire à
quel point je suis
blessé aujourd'hui j'ai eu mon dernier
câlin avec mon neveu aujourd'hui ce
matin à 11 heures ils étaient si heureux
je n'ai jamais pensé que c'était la
dernière fois que je voyais mon neveu
je veux lui dire repose en paix le même
jour une vidéo de l'arrestation de
daniel clowes un homme noir de 41 ans
mort le 30 mars dernier une semaine
après avoir été interpellé par la police
et diffusée par la famille de la victime
ce 23 mars le frère de daniel paul houde
appelle la police inquiet de l'avoir vu
quitter son domicile
la vidéo commence alors que les agents
de police retrouve daniel pohdh
complètement nu dans les rues de
rochester dans l'état de new york
l'homme est alors menotté sous la pluie
et les agents décident de lui mettre une
cagoule sur la tête il se redresse à un
moment sur ses genoux
les agents décident de l'immobiliser au
sol la tête maintenu fermement contre
terre par un agent un autre lui appuyant
sur le dos avec son genou après plus de
deux minutes
l'homme ne bouge plus et le personnel
médical commence à lui faire un massage
cardiaque déclaré en état de mort
cérébrale il décède le 30 mars après
avoir été débranchée des machines de
survie l'autopsié conclut que son décès
était un homicide causé par les
complications d'une asphyxie dans le
cadre du contraintes physiques et révèle
également dans le sang de la victime du
pcp une drogue hallucinogène qui aurait
tendance à provoquer des comportements
antisociaux et violent l'a fallu part
d'un meurtre de sang froid et demande le
renvoi des agentes l'anr de la ville
tente de son côté de calmer la situation
j'ai passé un appel téléphonique pour
que mon frère obtiennent de l'aide pas
pour qu'il se fasse lyncher
vous êtes ici pour protéger et servir
mais en fait vous êtes ici pour protéger
et lynché je veux dire à la famille prod
je sais qu'ils sont frustrés en ce
moment mais soyez assurés que nous
allons faire tout notre possible pour
s'assurer que la vérité soit faite et
que la justice soit rendue
le procureur général de new york et le
chef de la police de rochester ont
déclaré qu'une enquête était en cours
sur les circonstances de cette mort
les policiers présents sur la vidéo sont
eux pour le moment toujours en exercice
la cour pénale internationale et paris
déplore une attaque grave contre la cour
condamnant les sanctions américaines à
l'encontre de fatou bensouda est la
procureur de la cour pénale
internationale a été inscrite sur la
liste noire des états unis après
plusieurs mois de menaces
à l'origine la demande d'ouverture par
washington d'une enquête pour crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité en
afghanistan à des sanctions également
imposé à fassi comme au choco autre
grande figure de la cpi leurs avoirs
éventuels aux états unis sont désormais
gelés et ils ont interdiction totale de
se rendre aux états unis et on en vient
à la ferme aval ni et ses nombreuses
interrogations l'union européenne vient
d'appeler moscou à une enquête et
n'exclut pas les sanctions des
discussions à ce sujet sont annoncés à
l'otan vendredi et aujourd'hui le
président biélorusse à lancer de lourdes
accusations alexandre lukashenko assure
détenir la preuve que les occidentaux
auraient falsifié les faits alors
pourquoi et bien pour le président
biélorusse il s'agit là de dissuader
moscou d'intervenir en biélorussie
secoué par un mouvement de contestation
inédit sied depuis un mois le point tout
de suite avec notre correspondant à
moscou en prenez cléroux le porte-parole
du kremlin s'était dans un premier temps
exprimé hier dans la soirée en rappelant
que alexeï navalni juste avant son
transfert vers l'allemagne avait subi de
très nombreux tests et qu'aucune
substance toxique n'avait été découverte
dans son organisme et s'est de nouveau
exprimé sur le sujet aujourd'hui il a
dit ne voir aucune raison à ce que
l'état russe soit accusé de la
dégradation de l'état de santé d'alexina
vanier je serai prudent en parlant
d'accusations lancées contre la russie
il n'y a pas d'accusation il n'y a
aucune raison pour que de telles
accusations soient formulées mais nous
sommes réticents à accepter des
accusations à cet égard quant au fond de
la question
le parquet général russe a envoyé une
demande d'aidé judiciaire à berlin elle
a été reçue par la partie allemande
il n'y a pas encore eu de réponse hier
lors d'une conversation ministère des
affaires étrangères notre ambassadeur à
berlin n'a pas non plus reçu
d'informations spécifiques sur les
résultats des recherches menées par les
spécialistes allemands qui leur ont
permis de conclure un empoisonnement
autre information notable cette fois en
provenance de biélorussie lors d'un
entretien entre le premier ministre
russe mickail michaud style et le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko celui ci prétend avoir en sa
possession des preuves et plus
précisément un enregistrement qui
mettrait en cause qui mettraient en
doute la déclaration des autorités
allemandes sur l'empoisonnement d'alexei
la vanille la chancelière allemande a
déclaré que certains voulaient clouer le
bec de navalni et maintenant varsovie
parle avec berlin nous allons tout
préparer et envoyer au fsb
il y a deux interlocuteurs qui disent
clairement qu'il s'agit d'une
falsification
il n'y a eu aucun empoisonnement de
navalni un groupe de spécialistes
d'après ce que je comprends à préparer
des faits pour merkel pour
l'administration allemande et peut-être
également la déclaration qu'elle a
réalisé ils ont agi ainsi pour je cite
apprendre à poutine à ne pas mettre son
nez dans les affaires de la biélorussie
vous voyez à quel point ces gens sont
hypocrites
une information à laquelle les autorités
russes n'ont pas encore réagi n'ayant
pas à leur disposition l'ensemble des
éléments mais le kremlin a rappelé à
toutes fins utiles sa détermination à
tirer toute la lumière sur cette affaire
en amérique du sud maintenant le pérou
sur un vaccin chinois les premiers
essais cliniques de phase 3 débute la
semaine prochaine
le pays comptabilise près de 30000 morts
liés aux copies de 19
hélène masquelier un groupe d'experts du
laboratoire chinois sinopharm arrive à
l'aéroport international de lima
objectif commencer les essais cliniques
de phase iii d'un vaccin contre le
coronavirus aujourd'hui l'entreprise
chinoise sinopharm a apporté le vaccin
avec lequel nous allons pouvoir coopérer
lors de cette phase iii des essais
cliniques
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une nouvelle
étape de la coopération entre la chine
et le pérou dans la lutte contre le
court aux navires us pékin qui a déjà
commencé à administrer le vaccin à ses
citoyens le mois dernier mais qui n'a
que peu de cas sur son territoire pour
mener ces tests au pérou selon les
médias locaux
pas moins de 6000 personnes se seraient
inscrits pour participer aux essais
cliniques
nous sommes contents car finalement
après toute cette préparation
nous allons pouvoir commencer les tests
nous disposons enfin du matériel qui
nous permettra de commencer ce travail
la semaine prochaine si l'efficacité de
ce vaccin est avéré c'est un pays tout
entier qui pourraient commencer à voir
le bout du tunnel
en effet avec plus de 650 7000 cas de
kobe 19 pour près de 29 mille décès liés
à la maladie
le pérou enregistre l'un des taux de
mortalité les plus élevés au monde
l'arabie saoudite confirme l'ouverture
de son espace aérien à tous les vols
entre israël et les émirats arabes unis
ciel la décision intervient à la suite
de l'aller retour historique entre abou
dhabi et tel aviv en début de semaine
est d'après une source de l'autorité
générale de l'aviation civile saoudienne
le royaume je cite va répondre
positivement aux demandes déposées par
les autorités emirati pour autorisé les
survols vers tous les pays
israël n'est pas explicitement cité son
existence n'étant pas formellement
reconnu par ryad
mais cette excepté le qatar le seul pays
confrontés à la fermeture de l'espace
aérien savent ou en tout cas à l'accord
avec les émirats pourrait permettre à
israël d'ouvrir de nouvelles voies
diplomatiques
elle c'est la vie d'emmanuel dupuy
président de l'institut prospective et
sécurité en europe
on sait que les émirats arabes unis sont
maintenant le troisième pays à avoir
normalisé leurs relations diplomatiques
avec israël après l'egypte en 1979 et la
jordanie en 1994 et l'autorisation du
survol de bure territoire saoudien qui
précisément ne mentionne pas israël mais
évidemment cela va permettre aux
passagers donc à destination de l'asie
donc de gagner évidemment une bonne
partie du temps qu'il mettait dont il
eut égard aux contournements obligé par
l'arabie saoudite ne ce n'est que le
prémice d'une tentative diplomatique
d'ouvrir d'autres relations
diplomatiques on évoque le fait que
bahreïn le soudan on a même évoqué le
maroc qui pourrait ou qui serait en tout
cas
sollicitée de la part du prince héritier
puisque le roi salman est encore
hospitalisé le prince héritier mohammed
bin salman qui évidemment est dans la
convergence diplomatiques avec le gendre
du président américain jared kushner qui
voit là d'une certaine façon une partie
de son plan du siècle légitimer
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images en
bulgarie des milliers de personnes se
sont de nouveau rassemblés aujourd'hui
dans le centre ville de sofia en ligne
de mire le projet de réécriture de la
constitution et 80 policiers auraient
été blessés 126 personnes arrêtées selon
les autorités
hier le président omen radeff a déclaré
que la démission du premier ministre et
de son cabinet était la seule issue à la
crise politique en turquie le président
r douanes a reçu aujourd'hui le
président de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme à ankara une visite
décriée par plusieurs associations
elle accuse le pouvoir turc eu de
nombreuses violations la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme à d'ailleurs placé
la turquie au second rang sur sa liste
des violations des droits de l'homme
enregistrées en 2019 une centaines de
soignants en afrique du sud ont
manifesté contre leurs mauvaises
conditions de travail
ils dénoncent également la corruption
liée à l'achat par le gouvernement
d'équipements de protection individuelle
antico vide le manque d'équipement a
déjà coûté la vie à plus rien
[Applaudissements]
retour en france avec le deuxième jour
du procès des attentats de charlie hebdo
et de l'hyper cacher le premier jour
était consacré à des éléments techniques
de la procédure
à la lecture de la synthèse du dossier
et aux déclarations des avocats dans le
box
onze suspects accusés d'avoir apporté un
soutien logistique aux frères fois çi et
à amedi coulibaly auteurs des tueries
qui ont fait 17 morts entre le 7 et le 9
janvier 2015
on fait le point depuis le palais de
justice de paris avec notre reporter
katia technique
la seconde journée de ce procès
historique a été consacrée aux enquêtes
de personnalité des accusés
sept prévenus se sont ainsi succédé pour
évoquer des éléments biographiques les
concernant donc pas question de
radicalisation de questions religieuses
cela sera abordée plus tard lors du
déroulé des faits ils ont juste parlé de
leur curriculum vitae leur parcours de
vie
ils sont accusés d'avoir apporté un
soutien logistique notamment fournissant
des armes aux trois terroristes les
frères kwasi et à mehdi coulibaly ils
ont tous versé dans la petite ou la
grande délinquance mais pour leur
défense eh bien ces sommes ne sont pas
responsables de d'actes de terrorisme
c'était juste des trafiquants ce n'est
pas une opinion partagée par les avocats
des parties civiles ni par les victimes
et par les orties civile c'est pourquoi
je vous propose d'écouter deux avocats
de parties civiles maître catherine ce
fat et m elie korchia à ce sujet la
deuxième et la troisième journée
d'audience
il ne va pas révéler énormément de
choses à travers ces interrogatoires de
curriculum vitae comme on les appelle
qui sont là pour retracer le parcours de
vie des des accusés je pense que
réellement les débats rentreront dans le
vif du sujet à partir de la semaine
prochaine
c'est intéressant on commence à écouter
ce que nous disent les accusés sur leurs
vies en tout cas sur les éléments
principaux de leur vie jusqu'au moment
des faits mais encore une fois ce n'est
pas là où nous découvrirons il nous
aurons des éléments de des éléments
particuliers sur le dossier annonce ans
à condition qu'ils soient condamnés bien
entendu puisqu'il bénéficie la
présomption d'innocence
s'ils sont condamnés bien sûr
contrairement à ce qui a été dit ce ne
sont pas des seconds couteaux sans eux
il n'y a pas d'attentats voilà et je
pense que des personnes qui sont
dans cette situation ne peuvent pas être
jugés comme des criminels de droit
commun
ce ne sont pas des crimes de droit
commun il faut ajouter que ce procès
hors norme se déroule dans des
conditions d'organisation très
particulière parce que outre la salle
d'audience il existe des salles de
retransmission pour que les centaines de
personnes qui vont venir assister au
procès puisse suivre donc
il y a des salles avec les victimes avec
les avocats des parties civiles avec le
public la presse et donc tout le monde
n'est pas réunies au sein de la même
salle d'audience il a des problèmes
techniques de retransmission du son
l'épidémie de coronavirus vient encore
compliquer les choses les gens sont
masquées qu'il s'agisse des avocats
comme des accusés qui ne peuvent retirer
le masque juste au moment où il
s'exprime
antoine comte l'avocat qui s'occupe des
victimes de charlie hebdo nous en parle
mon débat s'est par contre
l'organisation que ce procès que je
trouve quand même très particulière je
trouve que avoir un procès clac et comme
ça en plusieurs salles c'est extrêmement
difficile
ne pas permettre aux victimes d'être
avec leurs avocats avec les accusés avec
les magistrats
c'est aussi très difficile et c'est pas
conforme de mon point de vue à la
manière dont on doit mener un procès
dans ce pays demain suivront d'autres
audiences des prévenus qui n'ont pas été
entendus aujourd'hui avec une seule
ambition répondre à cette question
lancinante est ce que les prévenus
avaient conscience de mener une
entreprise terroriste lorsqu'ils ont
aidé les frères kwasi amedi coulibaly
après notre dame des landes une nouvelle
zad pourrait voir le jour sur les bords
de la loire
cette fois l'objectif est d'empêcher
l'installation d'un site industriel sur
des zones humides et sauvage le lui
avait déjà fait l'objet d'un bras de fer
entre l'état et les populations locales
pour l'implantation d'un d'une centrale
nucléaire
un combat vieux de 40 ans remis au goût
du jour à saint-viaud sur le site du
carnet en loire atlantique
renault parquet un seul mot d'ordre
éviter ça l'implantation d'un nouveau
site industriel au beau milieu d'une
zone humide et sauvage située en bord de
loire car c'est ici
que vivent des espèces d'animaux et de
plantes protégées à l'origine de ce
rassemblement le collectif stop carnet
pour qui le projet s'avère dangereux
pour l'environnement et les riverains
le premier point crucial c'est la
destruction de 51 hectares de zones
humides
nous sommes à nous sommes en risque ici
de submersion et les zones humides et
les marais sont extrêmement importants
pour la biodiversité et sont extrêmement
importants pour faire office en quelque
sorte je ne suis pas géographe de thermo
régulateur de tampon régulateur ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
effectivement c'est la faune et la flore
qui va être durement touché la faune
parce qu'il ya dix espèces en 110
espèces faune et flore ya cent seize
espèces menacées et sur ceux sur ce site
il y à un des derniers couloirs
migratoires et les oiseaux qui viennent
s'est reposé pour construire ce site
industriel de 110 hectares fait de béton
et de remblai ce sont selon ce même
collectif
pas moins de 550 camions par jour qui
circuleront autant dire toujours plus de
pollution alors depuis samedi dernier
des tentes des installations de fortune
et des barricades ont fleuri un peu
partout sur le site
la résistance s'organise sous forme de
nouvelles zones à défendre une zad on
est une zone autonome qui cherche à se
défendre face aux agressions industriels
les grosses machines de chantier on est
sur une impasse qui en théorie interdite
au public et donc c'est totalement
barricades et si tu rentres tu es dans
la zone à partir du moment où tu es dans
la zone
tu respectes donc je prends pas de
photos des gens et puis tu es chez toi
sinon en fait tout le monde peut venir
la paix n'y a pas de keufs à l'entrée
qui va dire qui tu es et tu as droit de
rentrer ou pas et tout voilà c'est une
zone libre si les états et les keufs
nous laisse tranquille il y aura aucune
violence ça serait un truc sympa on va
faire des potagers des ateliers
réparation vélo ont choisi nous mêmes
nos règles maintenant envie de
s'organiser au quotidien en discussion
soit collective un peu fort mais qu'on
peut appeler des ag soit en petits
groupes et on a envie de faire sa vision
elle fait pour l'heure une cinquantaine
de personnes sont entrés en résistance
d'autres sont encore attendues dans les
semaines à suivre
contacté par téléphone le port de nantes
saint nazaire n'a pas répondu à nos
questions nouvelles affaires
compromettantes pour l'entreprise
lafarge le cimentier français est
accusée d'avoir déversé du béton et du
plastique dans la seine l'entreprise
parle je cite d'un accident exceptionnel
provoquée par un acte malveillant et
n'est en rien volontaires là le maire de
paris dénonce un scandale écologique et
annonce avoir saisi le procureur de la
république à lille a famous déjà épinglé
par le passé pour ses supposés liens
avec des jld
une mise en examen pour financement du
terrorisme et mise en danger de la vie
d'ancien salariés d'une usine en syrie
lafarge se retrouve à nouveau au coeur
d'un scandale
et cette fois ci ça se passe ici même à
paris dans le quartier de bercy
dans cette vidéo on voit un camion de
cimentiers déverser ses eaux usées dans
un bassin de décantation et via un trou
dans la cuve l'eau s'écoule directement
dans la seine dont le rejeter des
particules de ciment mais aussi des
tiges plastiques utilisés pour rendre le
béton plus résistant des déchets qui
étouffe les poissons époux lui la fleur
de la scène des images tournées le 27
août dernier par jacques lemoine un
garde pêche pour qui cet incident est
loin d'être accidentel
clairement ces volontaires dans ses
cuves se sont toutes les eaux les restes
de béton fabriqués dans la journée qui
reviennent dans les camions en fin de
journée ensuite la société est censé
traiter ces déchets seulement sur ce
site
elle ne le fait pas et elle se permet de
le rejeter dans la scène volontairement
et selon les gardes-pêche lusine
déverserait ses eaux usées depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
pour preuve elle accouche de ciment
sécher visible sur les quais lafarge se
targue pourtant de prêter une grande
attention à l'environnement
nous avons tenté à plusieurs reprises de
joindre le cimentier
sans succès lafarge s'est contenté de
nous envoyer un communiqué dans lequel
le groupe se dit victime d'un acte de
vandalisme en avril 2019
l'élu de la france insoumise danielle
simonnet alertait déjà sur la présence
d'une centrale à béton du groupe lafarge
en zone inondable dans le 15e
arrondissement
elle demandait à la ville de paris
d'annuler le permis de construire
accordés aux cimentiers les riverains
nous alertaient sur le fait que lafarge
n'hésitez pas à rejeter dans la seine
les eaux usées quand il nettoyait les
camions toupies quoi et qui avait aussi
un problème sur le bac le réservoir des
eaux usées qui pouvaient déborder s'est
coulé dans la seine la ville c'était
quand même engagé à réétudier le permis
de construire est asocial asocial et
vivra mais en fait les riverains ont été
très peu associés et la ville ayant déjà
accordé le permis de construire je
trouve n'a pas mené la bataille mais
surtout sur les questions
environnementales liées à la scène la
ville n'avait absolument pas bouger rien
n'avait été fait aucune réponse à
l'époque de la mairie de paris
depuis les choses ont peut-être un peu
changé
la mairie socialiste qui doit sa
victoire aux dernières municipales à une
alliance avec les écologistes s'est
montré plus réactive
c'est un véritable scandale écologique
alors que nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires depuis de nombreuses années
pour améliorer la qualité du fleuve
la ville de paris va saisir le procureur
de la république pour ces faits graves
qui portent atteinte à notre
environnement
accident ou acte délibéré par souci
d'économie une chose est sûre avec ce
nouveau caillou dans la chaussure le
cimentier va devoir bétonner sa défense
est ce la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes rester avec nous sur les france
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons terme la stratégie de
conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de